although it not part of the official
Cannon of the Star Wars Universe the
Star Wars holiday special came out not
long after the first film and de set
between a New Hope and The Empire
Strikes Back It Centers on chewbaca and
Han Solo's attempt to visit the planet
kashik or being pursued by Imperial
forces and Bounty Hunter Boba Fett the
$1 million budget which was around 10%
of the total cost of a new hope is
equivalent to more than $4.5 million
today so the special was certainly
inexpensive production the show was
universally panned by almost everyone
who has seen it even those who worked on
the project including cast members such
as Mark Hamill Carrie Fischer and
Harrison Ford have been critical of the
project and how it turned out do you
remember making this Christmas special I
think it was
1978 now you don't remember it Star Wars
Creator and director George Lucas has
even remarked that he wants to destroy
every copy of the special that is still
available